Bon, vous allez vous moquer de moi
(rires choupinous de votre vidéaste favori)
J'ai découvert il y a seulement un peu plus plus d'un mois
que vous m'envoyez des messages sur Insta, des messages privés je veux dire.
Pour ça en fait il faut appuyer dans le bouton "demandes d'invitations"
et là y a toutes les conversations qui apparaissent mais en fait
avant j'avais que des conversations de groupe. Donc je comprenais pas trop ce que c'était.
Je pensais que c'était que pour faire des groupes, et caetera.
Mais en fait pas du tout!
En fait, y'a pleins de gens qui peuvent t'envoyer des messages en perso!
Et je ne savais pas!
Et oui, on a beau être un gros influenceur (rires choupinous de votre vidéaste favori)
C'est la honte mec… ( un peu )
Et à chaque fois que je raconte ça à quelqu'un il fait:
"Mais attends? Tu déconnes, quoi?!"
Il me prend de haut. Hé oooh!
J'ai le droit de découvrir les choses et de parfois ne pas être à la pointe de la dernière nouveauté?
S'il vous plaît!
En fait, les seules fois où je parle à des gens par Insta, c'est des gens que je suis, et donc ducoup ils n'apparaissent pas dans le truc demandes d'invitations.
J'sais plus comment ça s'appelle.
Ils apparaissent dans le truc de base.
Bref, tout ça pour dire que j'ai découvert y'a un peu plus d'un mois cet onglet-là et je m'amuse à parfois vous répondre.
Et à lire vos messages, les mettre en story par exemple pour les tubes de l'été.
Et heureusement que j'ai découvert ça avant de faire les hits de l'été, sinon j'aurais rien mit du tout en story et c'est dommage.
Parce que ça fait vivre le truc et tout. Enfin bref.
Et j'ai trouvé un délire qui est trop drôle
Vous êtes pleins à vous amusez à créer des groupes.
Alors y'a certains de ces groupes qui sont créés juste pour la blague.
Où ils ne mettent que des personnalités dedans. Et y'en a d'autres où y'a genre cinq/six potes de lycée dedans où ils invitent des personnalités en plus dans le groupe,
mais ils font comme si ils ne les avaient jamais invités et eux parlent dans le groupe depuis genre, des jours et des jours, voir des mois.
C'est vraiment leur conversation de potes officielle.
Mais que je peux voir moi puisque ils m'ont invité au tout début quand ils l'ont crée.
Et c'est ces conversations-là que j'adore rejoindre car ils ne s'y attendent pas du tout.
et du-coup quand t'arrives c'est vraiment marrant, souvent ça crée des trucs
Soit des réactions genre : "oh mais what the fuck"
Soit, tout l'inverse,
vous me parlez normalement, comme si on avait toujours été potes
et j'adore je trouve ça génial cette ambiance !
Voilà, je découvre un truc un peu tard, mais vaux mieux tard que jamais !
C'est parti ! Rejoignons quelques groupes, j'espère qu'il y en a, parce que des fois y'en a pas beaucoup,
des fois y'en a pas trop pendant un moment mais y'en a d'autres plus tard mais ça varie quoi.
*il lit* Cyprien, Amixem, Bigflo et Oli, etc.
Vous voyez celle-là elle est parfaite
*message vocal* : "Charlotte t'es vraiment trop gentille hein"
*Rire*
Je tombe sur quoi là ???
j'vais tomber sur des trucs glauques.Qu'est ce qu'il passe ?
Alors attend c'est quoi la genèse de cette conversation
Pourquoi elle existe ?
*Message vocal* : Ouais Mathieu *BIP* est en kiff sur moi mais j'suis pas en kiff sur lui.
*rire*
C'est horrible, j'espionne des gens quoi.
En même temps vous m'invitez !
Vous étonnez pas !
C'est pas du voyeurisme ce que j'fais,
je suis invité dans la conversation, je suis participant.
J'ai le droit !
Juste je suis un peu silencieux.
Donc Julie apparement y'a Mathieu qui est en kiff sur elle
Mais elle ,elle n'est pas en kiff sur lui.
Attends on va envoyer un message
On va envoyer un message !
"Julie, pourquoi t'es pas en kiff sur euuh sur  Mathieu ?
Il est a fond sur toi lui apparement j'ai vu auu au bahut.
*soupir*
J'suis plus jeune ,c'est officiel je ne suis plus jeune.
Ahh, il sont en train de répondre !
Ils sont en train de répondre !
Attends,on veut quand même savoir si Mathieu et Julie vont finir ensemble ou pas quoi !
On veut savoir le dernier ragot !
"C'est pas Julie,c'est Luisa qui est en kiff sur Mathieu"
"Bah oui, j'suis pas en kiff dessus moi"
Ah m*rde
Bah oui c'est Luisa !
Oh la la j'suis pas foutu de savoir ou est marqué le pseudo par rapport au message
Je croyais que c'était en dessous mais c'est au dessus.
Ah je me fatigue !
Bon allez suivant ! Suivant(en riant)
On va essayer de trouver des conv un peu cool...
Qu'est-ce c'est que ça ? Billy Royaume.
Là par exemple vous voyez,c'est une conv je suis dedans mais ils ont écris maiis des kilomètres de messages
Ça n'a aucun sens !
Soirée du 28...
Attends ,y'a une soirée ? Y'a une soirée mais on prévient pas !
Attendez, c'est cool, je suis invité à une soirée le 28 !
Est-ce que toi t'a une soirée le 28 ? J'suis pas sûre
"Excusez-moi,vous avez l'adresse ou quoi pour la soirée le 28 ?(effet de voix écho)
*rire*
Hmm y'a les autres qui se sont excités
"Heu les gars ,c'est Sasha, c'est pas moi qui l'ai ajouté"
Le mec il se tape l'incrust comme ça dans les discus.
*rire*
J'me fais recaler, c'est fouu !
Sasha ,tu crois vraiment que c'est le vrai peut être ?
"Mais Luisa ,j'veux juste t'aider avec Mathieu,
fin faut pas me repousser comme ça,
tu me dis si c'est trop intime et tout et que je me même de ce qui me regarde pas,peut être c'est le cas,
mais c'est bienveillant de ma part en tout cas.''
*rire*
Mirador supérieur à Bye bye ? Attends quoi ?
Attend-tend-tend pardon ? Vous osez m'inviter dans une conv qui a ce nom ?
On est dans le non respect maintenant vous et moi ?
Ça me dégoute !
Attendez ,on a des news de Luisa !
*Message vocal* : Cool mais c'est mon ex et j'l'aime pas.
AH M*RDE,m*rde c'est son ex !
La gaffe !
J'adore,Luisa elle en a rien à foutre.
C'est comme si j'avais toujours été leurs ami.C'est touchant !
Alors est-ce qu'on a des nouvelles de la soirée du 28 ?
C'est chez qui alors ?
"Sanjiv ,donne l'adresse à Squeezie vite p*tain !"
*Message vocal* : Commencez pas là, déjà j'suis en cours après, pourquoi vous me dites squeezie ?
*rire*
J'ADORE ! Je vous jure,je sais pas si c'est un délire mal placé ou quoi.
mais j'adore !
J'ai l'impression que je suis potes depuis des années avec ces gens.
Alors qu'on ne se connait pas !
C'est génial !
Et c'est qui ce délire d'avoir son téléphone en cours ?
Mais qu'est-ce que vous faites là ?
Mais c'est nous, nous les youtubers qui vous incitons à faire ce genre de choses ?
là les jeunes là ?
Ça va pas du tout !
L'adress svp,je dois demander à ma mère de m'emmener.
Voilà.
Alors bye bye supérieur à Mirador, qu'est ce qu'ils ont répondu là pour se justifier là.
*il lit* : Pardon Lucas.
Ca commence plutôt bien.
*Il lit toujours* : C'est réglé oups.
*rire*
Ils ont mit Bye Bye supérieur à Mirador maintenant.
EH BAH MERCI UN PEU DE RESPECT, pour votre youtubeur préféré !
Bon.
Trouvons d'autres conversations un peu là.
''Les STMG''.
Qu'est ce qu'ils font ? Ils passent le BAC ?
Aah ils passent le BAC !
*il fait un message vocal* : Courage pour le BAC là tout le monde, travaillez travaillez tr-travaillez,
sinon vous finirez par ne plus arriver à articuler et à dire correctement les mots comme moi.
*rire*
Voila, j'espère que ça leur a donné de la force.
*squeezizi lit* : MDRR j'suis choqué mais merci.
''merci squeezie t'es un bon wAllah."
*rire*
"Frais merci Squeezie tu gères la fafa."
Fermez insta et travaillez là.
*voix spéciale* Squeezie,
l'homme qui vient dans tes dm pour te crier dessus parce que tu es sur ton téléphone au lieu de travailler.
*lecture* : Tinquiète on va travailler merci.
*rire*
C'est drôle qui s'excuse d'être sur insta.